what you want to do
is find a hundred percent of them right
now people estimate we found about 90
percent of them
well that leaves 10 percent of asteroids
we don't know where they are
and whether or not they're going to
cross the earth's orbit with us there
anytime soon so we want to keep watching
the skies
and finding these things and then
you know you want 20 or 30 years notice
so you can do
something to
keep it from hitting the earth
[Music]
so peter hello richard how are you very
very well i'm going to start right out
of the gate yes come in hot
how do you feel about armageddon is this
the topic of today's
podcast it is sort of the topic of
today's podcast are you talking about
armageddon as in
the biblical sense of armageddon not the
biblical sense
of that place where the final battle
between good and evil happens
you could argue in some cases armageddon
no matter what it is
is going to refer to some sort of end of
the world scenario in this case i am
referring to the classic
and i am doing air quotes if you're
listening uh armageddon the movie
michael bay jerry bruckheimer bruce
willis
stars is the head of a plucky blue
collar you lost me at michael bay
yes uh it is the scenario where and the
reason it applies to today's show
is that there is an asteroid barreling
down on the earth
it will essentially wipe out everyone
billy bob thornton's essentially
the nasa guy perfect and there's
scenarios
yes of course and their idea to deal
with this
existential threat is to send up a
drilling team a deep drilling team the
best
deep drill drilling team to drill into
an asteroid i want to send up the worst
no you wouldn't want i mean it made
sense right of the gate go with the best
yeah
um and of course there's a great love
story with uh
young ben affleck and liv tyler and of
course liv tyler's father
aerosmith lead singer stephen tyler
and the song that was part of i don't
want to close my eyes
i don't want to close my eyes i don't
want to fall asleep
cause i miss you baby ladies and
gentlemen richard garner
so crooning aside it was huge it was a
huge movie it was one of these massive
blockbuster you know sort of disaster
movies
but it really put the scenario on the
radar of a lot of people
about yeah what would we do in that so
of course what do you do here
at the old uh what if headquarters you
ask those questions
what if we blew up an asteroid because i
don't know the answer do you know the
answer
ah i've heard a little bit about it but
i would like to
explore it a little bit more would you
like to defer to somebody who might know
the answer
i think we have a pretty good guest who
might be able to talk about
this at length we happen to have i think
the perfect guess for probably any what
if hypothetical
but this case in particular the one the
only bill nye the science guy
yes we were able to get bill nye the
science i love it when he joins us
well tell us more about him pete okay
bill nye is a scientist engineer
comedian
author and inventor he's also a man with
a mission
to help foster a scientifically literate
society
and to help people everywhere understand
and appreciate the science that makes
our world work
bill's classic show bill nye the science
guy was nominated for 23
emmys and won 19 and it paved the way
for a career in making science
accessible fun
and super cool and he's still doing
exactly that with his sensationally
entertaining
and informative podcast science rules
with bill nye
bill thanks so much for joining us we're
super happy to have you on the show
today
it's so good to be had well it's we all
love to be had
but before we get into the sort of the
bigger what if of
what if um we blew up an asteroid uh we
were talking off the top about
armageddon
and i'm assuming a you've seen it and b
i was thinking about what is it like to
watch a movie with bill nye
especially if they're science involved
because i imagine to be pointing out
what is sort of a stretch and what isn't
if you remember that 1998 classic
deep drilling into an asteroid was that
a even feasible and b
what did you think of how they handled
the science well here's the thing about
it you guys you don't want to blow it up
that's the surprising thing why
because you probably get a shower of
stuff that's on the same trajectory
you know you uh as they say
and i'm i only read about this i'm not
involved in research but bruce betts at
the planetary side he is deeply involved
in this
a lot of asteroids aren't solid rocks
they're
in the expression the charming
expression in astronomy is
uh they're rubble piles they're just um
a loose collection of rocks held
together by their mutual gravity
and so if you set off an explosion
explosive
near them you just disperse them but
their overall momentum wouldn't change
that much like
they blow apart but they'd still keep
coming they still keep coming at you
and so it's a very uh it's a
very high risk scenario or way to go
about
trying to deflect because it's raining
rocks basically is
is what you're saying like basically a
bunch of smaller meteorites
all over the place which would be just
as deadly i'm guessing it sounds like it
yeah
well maybe and you know maybe worse you
know if
they land all over the place instead of
one place
you know as we say if you like to worry
about things asteroids are great
bill they say nas they tell us that nasa
is tracking some 20
000 neos near-earth objects at any one
time
what does that process look like and you
guys
be proud canadian space agencies deeply
involved in that
you know the uh canadian space agency
has an
instrument on almost every mission that
ever flies that's not from
chinese uh space administration
so um uh what you want to do
is find a hundred percent of them right
now people estimate we found about 90
percent of
well that leaves 10 percent of asteroids
we don't know where they are
and whether or not they're going to
cross the earth's orbit with us there
anytime soon so we want to keep
watching the skies and finding these
things
and then you know you want 20 or 30
years notice
so you can do something send bruce
willis or whatever you want to do
something
to keep it from hitting the earth and
then there's this whole other thing
about
mitigation where you get everybody to
leave
winnipeg so if it lands there everybody
you'll be okay
but this is a very these are
extraordinary things because
the earth is turning the earth's going
through space and these
objects are largely rock but many of
them also have ice
and then there's other objects that you
don't you can't see
near them so their trajectory is
pretty predictable but there are errors
or unknowns on the order of a few days
or let's say half a day
so is it going to land in winnipeg or
vancouver
or tokyo it's like whoa you can't really
be sure oh the ice
will uh volatize will evaporate we'll
out gas
that's a good one give the thing a
little nudge
so predicting it is is uh
difficult to predict it within with
accuracy enough to evacuate cities for
example
and people have thought deeply about
this and so that's why we want to find
them all
and get ready to give it a nudge yeah it
sounds like the nudge the deflection is
the is the way to go
a good hockey uh reference there the old
deflection uh we have a question from
our
um [ __ ] yeah the defenseman just puts a
stick near it and it
goes over the goalie's shoulder yeah um
so we have a hard enough time tracking
them right now like you said 90
they're still 10 we have all this
incredible technology telescopes etc
and now imagine going back to our poor
friends the dinosaurs who didn't have
that ability that forewarning
and we know about that particular
existential
event for them uh we have a question
from somebody in the
what if community karthik narayan
asks what if an asteroid the size of one
that killed the dinosaurs
came close to earth didn't necessarily
hit us but got let's say within our
orbit
close enough to affect the moon or us is
there danger there as well
well there's a saying an alliterated
saying a miss is as good as a mile
and mile may not be a reference
accessible to many canadian listeners
anymore
but it's you know a kilometer and a half
that if it misses it misses
in general but if it hits it's really
bad
so uh on the my podcast science rules we
had uh
jacques jacqueline the woman who did the
analysis on the crater
in off chicxulub what is now chick
salute mexico
and the thing came in so fast how fast
was it
it is supposed that it made the
atmosphere into a plasma
this is to say the atmosphere got so hot
there locally
uh that the electrons dissociate from
their
atoms and the air became opaque
wow it became so hot that
it wasn't transparent to sunlight
anymore for you know a few seconds
and then uh the wind from it got to what
is now
france in a few hours in other words the
impact was so
big and so uh catastrophic that it
affected uh the world and this is where
geologists you know
when i was in school when i was in
elementary school primary school
nobody really knew what happened to the
ancient dinosaurs but now everybody's
confident in this
that this was the reason the cone of the
ejected material the ejecta
was bigger than the diameter of the
earth wow
what yeah and then
this material that we all love so much
iridium
atomic number 77 it's over there
atomic number 77 is all
over the earth because of this
impact and so if it were to
hit that's what happens if it were to
miss
i mean not much would happen you presume
if i understand her question
uh the thing is 30 kilometers across you
know uh
20 20 miles across and uh that's huge
but compared to the earth it's not that
big i mean it's not big at all it would
just go
streaking by would it do anything to the
gravity of the moon or anything like
that that's what i was just pondering
i'm just thinking out loud i don't think
it's big enough
you know we had an earthquake what six
years ago that
gave the earth's axis a nudge so i'd
have to
really it would i think it's a clear
example of there's no question
absolutely it depends yeah it depends
how big the asteroid is how fast it
literally is going and then how close it
came but
i would imagine it would be measurable
but not
sensible in other words we have
instruments that would measure the
gravity deflected
the deflection due to its gravity and
motion
but uh humankind a person couldn't feel
it i'm imagining
well we're gonna we're first of all this
is great stuff
uh we're gonna continue with bill nye
to talk about what if we blew up an
asteroid and everything else and
also talk about a few other cosmological
scenarios
but uh bill there's another podcast i
want to say a better podcast
another podcast just as good that people
might be interested in
might be better called science rules
with a guy named bill nye tell us about
that
uh so it's uh it's a podcast i do
uh in two versions uh every week we have
somebody on
um who was an expert in his or her field
talking about something cool
we had um the gal talking about the
asteroid impact it's
just this thing when you're under
pressure uh uh
uh jacqueline anyway talking about the
asteroid impact we had
uh uh expert on psychopathy
wow if you're a psychopath that she
pronounces psychopathy
we have uh we have uh every
uh every two weeks we do a coronavirus
edition where we're talking about
what's happening with this pandemic and
uh how serious it is in the u.s you know
and i
you guys uh as canadians i presume
you're like everybody else my colleagues
i have friends in denmark and
in japan they're just shaking their
heads like what are you guys doing
a little bit this goes back to the the
beginning of the u.s where
just these systems these legal systems
were in place that just are
have real limitations that we're going
to have to overcome
in the next election god speed
yes god speed with that
okay great bill thanks very much for
joining us on the video podcast
uh we really appreciate it thanks for
promoting my podcast
no problem meanwhile be safe out there
you all
it's a dangerous world for us right now
will do
thanks bill wow so
bill nye a guy who knows a lot also a
guy
who probably never stops learning
doesn't sound like it doesn't no
and i think you're a guy who likes to
never stop learning am i right
not to the same level of absorption
let's say as a guy like bill nye the
science guy but yes i love to learn i
love to continue to learn just like we
do every week on this show
well now is the time to continue your
studies or your learning because
you know with covert 19 we're all at
home we've got most of us have a little
bit of extra time
to learn well why don't you become more
informed creative
inspired relaxed all with the great
courses plus
we're really big fans of this aren't we
well so i was at home the other day and
this sounds made up but it isn't i'm
going
i'm sitting on my smart tv because i
just moved so i'm going through the apps
available on my smart tv
there's our old friend
greatcoursesplus.com i'm thinking maybe
i could jump in and get prepared for the
bill nye episode
moon rocks there's a whole episode on
moon rocks from the apollo mission
uh this uh professor bob hazen is
talking about this
is in his words the scientific bonanza
that that created
50 years ago when they just came home
with a few rocks for the moon you'd
think well that's kind of what is it a
paperweight no they've been actually
gleaning
tons of scientific info and then all of
a sudden we're talking to bill
nye earlier and he's talking about moon
rocks and how
they've actually helped us understand
what the age of
our planet continents here uh you know
minerals and elements in the earth like
it's incredible the amount of knowledge
we've been able to glean from moon rocks
and incredible the amount of knowledge i
was able to glean from a great corpses
plus
episode that i was getting ready for
this show well let me tell you the great
courses plus has not only that but
thousands of lectures on almost any
topic imaginable
from the history of egypt to the study
of dna and
new courses are added all the time
there's someone for everyone not just
moon rock lovers like yourself plus
every course is presented like you say
by subject matter experts from top
universities and institutions it's
in-depth reliable
fact-based information and you can watch
or listen from your phone
or your tv with the great courses plus
app at any time
from anywhere in the world so make the
most of your time keep learning with the
great courses plus
right now they're offering fans of this
show an amazing deal
an entire month of access for free this
limited time offer won't last so sign up
today to get started
go to thegreatcoursesplus.com
what if don't wait go to the great
courses
plus what if
i think you meant to say
thegreatcoursesplus.com
what if that's i think exactly what i
said so let's go there and get your free
month
so perhaps not surprisingly well maybe
it was surprising to people listening or
watching but
if you blow up a massive asteroid there
is that sort of
other piece of the puzzle which is i
don't know
the trillion pieces of that puzzle that
are going to turn into many
sort of meteors right and all of a
sudden it's not raining men it's
it's raining and still there's maybe the
disaster is spread out and it's not as
existential in terms of the impact but
you're still going to have massive
damage
yeah and i don't know if it's not going
to be as existential i mean
bill said it himself that it could be
even worse you know i
don't know what the number would be a
million meteors crashing into earth
like that would be devastation on all
corners of the planet rather than just
concentrated one area
yeah one thing i didn't know about
asteroids is that they're not
necessarily one large rock
yes that they are a cluster of much
debris or whatever or but i mean or
rubble i think yeah the word he used
yeah but it's interesting because really
okay first of all deflection
is the only scenario yeah really at the
end of the day it's rerouting
something whether whether it's lasers
whether it's some sort of explo whatever
it is
it's not going to be blow it up it has
to be push it
off course away from the earth that's
pretty much it and again that the the
lead up you'd need again
you'd have to know it's coming and as he
talked about we know where a lot of them
are coming
90 we know where 90 of them are did that
did that reassure you peter that there's
10
that we don't know uh no i was surprised
but i was waiting to hear
we know 98.9
and there's maybe a couple of surprises
ten percent's a big window 10
is a big window but in just envisioning
how large
space is like i don't blame anybody from
this i'm missing ten percent
on the way i'm not throwing shade at the
people
man in the telescope you're on the
millennium falcon going through a
a meteor field can you count all those
things in there no and i mean and again
that's that incredible piloting skill of
han solo
but no i mean it is interesting that
really this is scenario that's been
talked about we talked about it off the
top with movies
and whatever and really it's not
feasible because the the question marks
the downsides the risk versus the reward
factor too high
it seems like uh you know the more you
talk about these scenarios which get
entertained
whether it's through sci-fi or whatever
it else it is
you realize that yeah you want to be
prepared but you can only be prepared
for so much and in this case this
doesn't seem
like going up there with a nuclear bomb
and blowing up an asteroid is even
on the table no not at all well
if you enjoyed our chat with bill nye
the science guy and want to hear
more with him well join us in the
extended audio version just click on the
link in the description below
and we'll have more with bill nye the
science guy he'll join us and we'll talk
more about
exploding nuclear bombs in space and
possible
extinction level events the
scenarios the ideas about what to do
with an asteroid are just
fantastic make a spacecraft so big how
big would it be that it's gravity
would could be used to tug the asteroid
a gravity tug
ship tug the asteroid off of course a
little bit
uh then you mentioned setting off a
nuclear weapon in the hopes that
the expanding gases or atoms would give
the asteroid a nudge
or give it set it off so that the
material of the asteroid itself would
have momentum
to give the asteroid a nudge lots more
interesting stuff with bill nye in the
extended audio version
we'll see you next time on what if
[Music]
discussed